matpat 70 kilograms laptop 2 kilograms
diet coke 5 cans and trace amounts of 12
other elements was that an episode of
film theory
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where let's be honest who doesn't have a
crush on win rate right I can't be the
only one so back in our Walking Dead
episode last December I asked you guys
one simple question little did I know it
was going to be one of the most divisive
hate-filled
drama inducing questions to ever be
asked on YouTube did you want an episode
about sword art online or Full Metal
Alchemist
let me tell you it was the anime
equivalent of World War three reaching
Marvel vs. DC levels of aggression in
the comments over 200,000 of you voted
by a margin of only 10,000 votes FMA
took the day and so here we are that
being said if you haven't seen the
series why not it's widely considered to
be one of the best most important animes
of all time granted I'll be filling you
in on the main details here but be
warned there are some minor spoilers
ahead so you guys had spoken but what to
do it on there's so many good topics
here it's a show with everything from
living suits of armor to parallel
alternate universes with different
scientific fundamentals to a main
character with an irrational fear of
Bill I debated across all kinds of great
topics for this first theory on full
metal literally looking at every part of
the franchise from the two anime series
manga the movies the ridiculously
adorable alphonse hat collections and in
all honesty it's a series I'm gonna want
to visit a few more times I mean would
you look at these things there is
clearly a theory here about how cute
they are maybe for like fashion theory
but before we get into the
multi-dimensional element bending
homunculus we have to start with the
fundamentals the inciting action for
literally everything that happens in the
series human transmutation and the one
big mistake that seals
edie and ELLs fates Full Metal Alchemist
has been lying to us for years and it's
not about the importance of a soul or
the girth of major armstrong's right
bicep it's something much simpler and
simultaneously something much more
important now in the 2003 version of The
Full Metal Alchemist series which is the
one I'm going to focus on today we learn
early on that Ed and Al were both
prodigies in the art of alchemy the
science of understanding the atomic
makeup of materials breaking those
materials down and reshaping the
components
to a new form probably the most common
example from the show is taking a metal
arm and turning it into a metal blade
most of their early alchemy lessons came
from their dad but not their actual dad
because you know he was a total deadbeat
but their dads library and the best or
worst volume and old Hohenheim 's
collection is his book on human
transmutation of forbidden art in the
alchemy world it's a good job dad you
leave your book on the most taboo
subject in all of alchemy lying around
your house with your two kids who
basically have zero supervision because
you're off doing whatever and their mom
seems to constantly be hanging up
laundry outside
like seriously woman are there really
that many clothes to launder anyway the
inciting incident to the whole series is
when ed and Al's mother dies at the
hands of the laundry gods I guess and
they try to use human transmutation to
bring her back to life this to say
doesn't go all that well ed loses a leg
al loses his whole body and instead of
mom they create this worst Mother's Day
ever and this in turn prompts the rest
of the series as the two boys try to get
their bodies back together come on why
did things go wrong in the first place
why did their attempt at transmuting mom
fail so horribly the show would have you
believe it's because the soul is
priceless and that there's no equivalent
exchange for it I would have you believe
that that is crap the solution is much
simpler than that they have the wrong
formula you heard me right the recipe
for human transmutation that we hear ed
recite over water 35 liters and over
carbon 20 kilograms and over ammonia for
leaders throughout the series is just
plain wrong sir so today I'm correcting
that mistake and showing you what our
buddies Ed and Al should have done
before they went off resurrecting mom
double-checking their math looks like
old Hohenheim of Light Plus at the
brightest bulb in the box get it on time
of Lake balm so light Oh what am I doing
with my life so in full metal alchemist
on conservation of mass which is why
everything is in units of grams and
kilograms but when it comes to creating
a human you need to get a little bit
more specific than that a little bit
more chemistry and if you're like
everyone in full metal alchemist and
haven't had a sophomore chemistry class
well get ready to get
science on my friends based on the Laura
full metal alchemist we know that the
humans in the world of the show are
meant to be the same humans in our world
as such we can actually use real science
like chemistry from over on this side of
the gate to correct the fictional
alchemy mistakes that they make over
yonder way and it just so happens that
over on this side we have accurate
measurements of the composition of the
human body originally generated by the
US Bureau of chemicals and soil which
yes used to be a real US Department
truly this was a department for people
who want to work in the government but
didn't want that flashy lifestyle of the
DMV anyway they've broken down the human
body into the elemental masses it
contains grades we can just check these
figures against Ed's calculations and
are you kidding me it's never easy the
US Bureau of chemicals and soils break
them down by elements but that's a
problem because for Ed's calculations he
sometimes uses in elements like
phosphorus and other times he uses a
molecule like salt which is two elements
together sodium and chlorine and a CL
but okay if I can figure out the
fictional height of chun-li I can get
around this little hurdle all I need to
do is break down the components and uses
into its respective elements then run
the math and come up with the amount of
each element the series says you need to
cook up a healthy helping of human we
then compare that with reality and get
our answer so step one is get all Ed's
fun list of human ingredients into
Graham's head though also can't seem to
decide if he wants to work in units of
volume or in mass so he puts water and
ammonia into liters and everything else
into grams and kilograms this lame but
whatever it's an easy fix by running
both of those through converters great
now we have grams of everything uh Ned's
list but we need to convert them from
the weight of molecules into the weight
of the raw elements they contain to do
that we have to do more than just add
and subtract that's right ladies and
gentlemen we will have to multiply and
divide
hold onto your auto mail here we go you
see in order to compare our two lists we
need to get the number of grams for
certain elements in our body but one x
list in the show mixes pure elements
with compounds like water and saltpeter
making our job a bit more complicated to
get from grams of a compound to grams of
an element we have to use our empirical
formulas these formulas basically help
you do math on a molecular level because
when you're talking about atoms in a
molecule you have to talk about the
number of atoms before you can even
start talking about mass it's actually
something that FM a completely glosses
over think about it like this I have 10
kilograms of hamburgers each one has one
patty in two buns I have a manly man
looking to get my hash tag games on so I
want to know how much of that 10
kilograms is just the meat protein raw
well to get there first I have to know
the weight of the beef and one patty for
one burger then I can figure out how
much meat I'm packing by finding the
percent of the total hamburger that's
just meats and applying that percentage
to the whole ten kilograms of burger
goodness Oh
McDonald's he sounds so good right now
hash tag not sponsored but hash tag
could be sponsored McDonald's anyway the
same thing applies to the Elric list
think of our water molecule h2o as the
hamburger of the chemistry world where
the oxygen is the beefy center and the
hydrogen's are our buns and says that we
need 35 thousand grams of water to
create a human but how many grams of
hydrogen do I have versus grams of
oxygen well just like needing to know
the number of burger patties I had we
need to know how many atoms we have of
each element since the hydrogen atom
weighs a lot less than an oxygen atom
and because this is chemistry and not a
barbeque we have to do all that in
molecular terms do that we'll be using
moles or that's probably causing some of
you watching to have PTSD from your high
school science days hey at least I'm not
bringing up sig figs right a mole is a
word chemists use instead of a really
big number 6.02 times 10 to the 23rd
power it's like if a baker says a dozen
we know he means 12 unless he's
referring to a baker's dozen in which
case he means 13 and making this a kind
of a bad example if a chemist says a
mole they mean 6.02 times 10 to the 23rd
seriously science this is why people
take Women's Studies majors in college
for every element there's a molar mass
for
elements which is the number of moles in
a single gram of it it sounds
complicated but it's just a ratio that
lets you flip back and forth between
grams and moles whenever you're solving
problems like this so here's how we're
gonna use it we start with grams of a
compound like h2o then we turn it into
moles using our ratio for molar mass
where did we get this random number for
the molar mass of water you can
calculate it by using the periodic table
or you can just look it up on Google
I'll let you guess which one I did for
water our magic molar mass ratio is 18
point O two grams per mole we put in
Edward's thirty-five thousand grams of
water from his list and multiplied by
one mole over eighteen point O two grams
of water to get 1942 point three moles
of water that takes us from the weight
of our water to the number of water
molecules we have now we have to
calculate how many hydrogen's we have so
we can figure out how much those guys
weigh this time we use the molar mass
for each individual element which again
I of course use the periodic table for
not Google at all for water the two
hydrogen's take up only 11 percent of
the molar mass an oxygen takes up 89
percent knowing that we calculate 11
percent of 1942 point three to get two
hundred and thirteen point six five
moles of hydrogen and one thousand seven
hundred twenty eight point six three
moles of oxygen and just so you know I
didn't just do this with water I did it
for the salt the saltpeter the ammonia
basically all the other molecules had
mentions where we needed to split them
into their elements it's the exact same
formula for all of them so I'm saving
you a lot of time watching me plug in
numbers into my calculator the magic of
editing let's fast forward shall we I
asked the ladies to make saltpeter for
gunpowder tell us how saltpeter is made
by treating sodium nitrate with
potassium chloride of cause okay now we
have all our elements ah but they're
still in moles I hate moles
except for your Cindy Crawford so to get
back to grams we just reverse our
equation from before except now we're
doing it by the elements and what do we
have to show for it well for one a
really really solid reason why hardly
anyone has ever called him to question
the fullmetal formula before I mean who
who is nerdy enough to do this sort of
thing but more importantly we have all
the masses of the elements ed plans to
use to create a human being before we
compare that to the real-world list
though did you make it through all the
math congratulations good job here's a
hamster eating a carrot under a blanket
as a reward
see learning is fun so if that hamsters
carrot snack properly chewed it's
finally time to compare the mass of each
element from the series versus the mass
of each element as it actually appears
in the human body you can see that there
are a few elements that manage to come
close phosphorus and sodium are probably
our closest within 10% of the actual
mass found in a human body so that's not
too shabby but then things start to go
downhill from there the worst offenders
are actually potassium and silicon where
they're off by anywhere between 50 and
300% and there's all kinds of ranges in
between
sulfur's off by more than half chlorines
way off each other these aren't even
close but that begs the question does
any of this matter what would this
actually do if we were trying to create
a human using these materials he'll hate
to break it to you but it actually
matters a lot three hundred percent of
normal fluorine levels would make your
bones and teeth super brittle having
half the amount of sulfur you need would
cause a whole rainbow of symptoms from
acne to arthritis to memory loss because
of alt hydrogen and oxygen or volts 25
to 35% too low we know there's a lot of
water missing in fact it's so low that
whatever version of a tinel's mom they
create would be incredibly dehydrated
possibly to the point that her systems
wouldn't even function to begin with and
with about 70% of our potassium missing
it's likely that her heart would never
even start beating because potassium is
one of the key elements that cause
electrical potential in your heart and
nerves literally
the chemical that makes your heart run
the bottom line is that even from the
very beginning had an Al we're starting
out with an alchemical that doesn't
equal a human it's like trying to make
bread with a recipe for spaghetti turn I
don't know something else that's
definitely not bread the proportions are
just wrong it's no wonder they created
this monstrosity that half formed human
is probably the best they could do using
the materials they had they were nowhere
close to having the elements necessary
to make a complete person forget souls
at the end of the day the thing holding
them back the most had nothing to do
with the Philosopher's Stone or their
knowledge of taboo alchemy it had to do
with their own math every time Edie
recites that formula in all those
episodes he's not reminding himself of
his mother he's ruining any chance of
her ever existing again and that loyal
theorists is why you always measure
twice and transmute your dead mother
once but hey that's just a theory of
film theory and guts you know equivalent
exchange is all about trading one thing
for another
well screw that you can break the laws
of equivalent exchange right now by
transmuting your way to a one-month free
trial of unlimited ad-free HD anime with
crunchyroll nothi Sochi the anime
streaming service just use the link in
the description or type in
crunchyroll.com slash matpat it's like
your personal Philosopher's Stone you
give up nothing in an exchange you get
30 days of free unlimited anime streamed
straight to your desktop tablet Xbox
Playstation Wii U Android iPhone Roku
and Roku it says it twice in the talking
points which is funny since I'm sure
like 0.2% of you actually use a Roku
look if you're accidentally gonna repeat
something at least let it be one of the
things that people under the age of 40
actually use anyway I'm still admittedly
a bit of a noob to anime so crunchyroll
has been a great service allowing me to
catch up on all the shows you've been
requesting I do theories on like Hunter
x Hunter and kill a kill but also giving
me the chance to revisit some of my
childhood favorite shows like Digimon
and Sailor Moon and that said I'm
currently looking for new anime to
theorize about so shatter the laws of
alchemy get a free trial by clicking the
in the description and then let me know
in the comments what series you want me
to theorize about next and look you
didn't even need a transmutation circle
to do it someone should tell the monkey
lie about this deal anyway if you'll
excuse me I need to catch up on Digimon
frontier which everyone tells me is the
best season and happens to be the one
that I missed so I'm gonna go watch that
now see you next week